So far we've been working with user
input by polling for it each frame.
The other approach to user input,
is an event based approach,
where we ask to be notified
when certain things happen.
To do this in LibGDX, we need to create
an implementation of the input processor
interface and
tell LibGDX to send events our way.
Let's check out how we've
done that in this demo.
We've now declared our BouncingBall
class to extend InputAdapter.
InputAdapter, just like
ApplicationAdapter and ScreenAdapter,
is a convenience implementation
of input processor.
One of the call back methods
of InputProcessor is keyDown,
which is called any
time a key is pressed.
The argument is the keycode of
the key that was just pressed.
In this case, we're just reusing
that randomKick function, and
we'll fire it any time
the space bar is pressed.
The return value of all InputProcessor
methods is a boolean signifying whether
the input event was handled.
This becomes relevant when you're
dealing with a more complex game,
where there may be multiple classes
responding to input events.
In this case, this is the only class
that cares about input events, so
we can go ahead and
say that we dealt with the event.
There's one more thing we need to do
before this works and that is we need to
tell LibGDX that this class is
interested in receiving input events.
The best place to do that,
is back in BallScreen, where we used
GDX.input.set.InputProcessor, passing
in our new ball object.
So here's our ball again.
And we can grow it and shrink it,
just like we could before.
And we can also move it around,
But now, if we hit spac ebar, it moves.
And if we hold down space bar,
it doesn't continue to move.
It only receives that event when
the space bar is initially pressed.